du jour appelle la discussion
d'application de l'article 34 Alina 1 de
la constitution de la proposition de
résolution relative à l'accord
commercial entre l'Union européenne et
le Mercosur
commençons donc par la discussion
générale avec Monsieur Pascal Lecan pour
le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
chers collègues
aux personnes d'autres
la résolution que nous votons
aujourd'hui est un appel à un nouveau
pacte de confiance
pour le libre-échange
je ne choquerai personne en disant que
j'ai poussé protectionnistes sont
nombreuses en tant que fervent défenseur
du commerce international je suis
convaincu qu'il faut les combattre non
pas en ignorant les premiers coupations
environnementales sanitaires ou sociales
qui les nourrissent parfois mais au
contraire en proposant un chemin
d'ouverture qui s'inscrivent ce commerce
international dans les transitions
il en est de notre responsabilité
or la Corion européenne Mercosur dans sa
forme négocier jusqu'à 2019
suit un logiciel complètement obsolète
selon une étude récente l'environnement
et la préoccupation principale de 60%
des Français des jeunes Français de 15 à
35 ans comment leur expliquer que nous
adoptions un texte qui causerait une
augmentation de plus de 5% de la
déforestation en Amazonie
comment justifier que la France qui a
accueilli la COP 21 et fait œuvre de ses
meilleurs talents diplomatiques pour
arriver aux accords de Paris accepte
aujourd'hui un texte qui ne fait pas de
leur respect une clause essentielle une
clause incontournable
l'accord Union européenne
Mercosur actuel c'est aussi
99000 tonnes équivalent carcasse de
boeuf sud américain
potentiellement élevé aux antibiotiques
importées sans droit de douane alors
même que nous avons à raison banni les
antibiotiques de croissance depuis le
1er janvier 2006 en Europe quel retour
en arrière ce serait au delà 27% des
ingrédients actifs utilisés au Brésil
sont interdits en Union Européenne la
concurrence déloyale le dumping social
et les risques sanitaires que cela
causerait sont injustifiables notamment
envers nos agriculteurs et en
particulier nos éleveurs à qui je le
rappelle on demande dans le même temps
d'assurer notre souveraineté alimentaire
nous disons à la Commission européenne
nous disons au gouvernement des États
membres de l'Union européenne ce texte
n'est pas le bon il faut en retravailler
la copie en toute transparence en cela
nous sommes alignés sur nos collègues
parlementaires à Bruxelles qui se sont à
l'initiative de ma collègue Marie-Pierre
Vedène opposé à l'accord dans sa forme
actuelle nous tenons évidemment à un
accord politique et commercial avec les
pays du Mercosur que sont l'Argentine le
Brésil le Paraguay d'Uruguay mais la
réciprocité dans les normes de
production des mesures miroirs le
respect des accords de Paris avec des
contrôles appropriés doivent être des
conditions non négociables il en va de
l'acceptabilité future du commerce
extérieur le président de la République
l'a dit dès 2019 et nous l'avons porté
pendant la présidente française de
l'Union européenne
l'absence de clause miroir doit être une
ligne rouge un franchissable dans nos
négociations
elle serait source d'écocides
dans cette enceinte nous exposons trop
souvent aux Français et aux françaises
des images d'affrontements trop souvent
stérile considérant l'urgence de la
situation et la forte pression pour
arriver à un accord avant le sommet
Union européenne Amérique du Sud des 17
et 18 juillet prochain en particulier du
gouvernement espagnol qui prendra la
présidence du Conseil le 1er juillet
je me félicite je me félicite que nous
ayons pu nous retrouver de manière
transpartisanale pour soutenir ce texte
d'intérêt général chers collègues
j'espère que nous serons envoyés un
signal fort en faveur d'un futur accord
Union européenne merco sourd plus juste
mais pas à n'importe quel prix votons
donc aujourd'hui unanimement pour cette
résolution je vous remercie je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Dominique
potier pour le groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre cher collègue
c'est une étude qui est parue en
exactement trois ans en 2020 c'est
l'étude Agrimonde comme toujours des
dizaines d'organisations internationales
en coopérer clean Reich chez nous le
Cirad l'AFD coopération internationale
une visée totalement partagée et c'est
une bonne nouvelle nous pouvons nourrir
10 milliards d'habitants en 2050 sur
cette planète nous pouvons il n'y a pas
de limite physique c'est possible il y a
simplement quelques conditions et ces
conditions nous amènent un
bouleversement une sortie des
trajectoires de développement qui sont
les nôtres aujourd'hui elles sont
simples pourtant arrêté avec la CAPAM
des terres partagez la terre assurer le
renouvellement des générations
garantissant une dignité d'un revenu à
tous les paysans ici et ailleurs partout
dans le monde
et puis le troisième point c'est
établir un commerce équitable non
seulement entre les espaces ruraux et
les métropoles mais entre les pays entre
les continents
commerces équitable dignité du revenu
des paysans protection des terres
agricoles nous pouvons nourrir le monde
c'est le défi de notre génération avec
cette autre défi qui est connexe et qui
participe qui en interaction qui est
celui du climat est-ce que le traité du
Mercosur répond à ces défis majeurs ces
défis sur lesquels nous serons jugés
dans 30 ans nos enfants nos petits
enfants nous demanderont ce que nous
avons fait en 2023 lorsque nous avons à
nous prononcer sur ces questions là et
je vous le dis monsieur le ministre on
cherchait la vraie formulation de la
phrase du cardinal de Retz sur
l'ambiguïté je vous invite aujourd'hui
à sortir de l'ambiguïté vous le
président de la République la première
ministre tous les exécutif sortait de
l'ambiguïté sinon ça sera aux dépens
nous dit aujourd'hui tous les études
d'un million d'hectares de l'Amazonie
qui pourrait être détruit au profit du
soja
au défi de notre sécurité alimentaire
parce que en détruisant l'Amazonie nous
contribuerons indirectement non
seulement l'accélération du dérèglement
climatique mais nous épuiserons une
partie de notre réserve de biodiversité
mais nous mettrons en péril l'économie
de nos élevages et notamment des 5
millions d'hectares qui constituent le
Massif Central et tout un écosystème qui
est une forme de réservoir d'eau de
l'ensemble de notre pays la France bref
si nous traitons si nous engageons dans
ce traité c'est nous ne sortons pas de
l'ambiguïté comme vous y êtes
aujourd'hui nous risquons non seulement
ce plan environnemental mais sur le plan
social sur le plan du respect des droits
humains des peuples d'Amazonie des
paysans d'Amérique du Sud et des paysans
de France et d'Europe d'avoir d'engagé
des processus irréversibles tant
interagissent les questions sociales et
environnementales il faut donc sortir de
ce traité c'est le sens de cette
résolution je salue Pascal Lecan et tous
les collègues qui à droite et notamment
à gauche se sont engagés sur ce sujet
nous avons réussi à nous réunir sur
commune manque-t-elle de clarté je ne le
crois pas une seconde nous demandons à
ce que soit séparé ne soit pas séparé le
traité commercial du traité global
est-ce que vous pouvez nous apporter des
réponses précises sur ce point est-ce
que vous pouvez ensuite nous dire que
vous militerez pour que cet accord soit
un accord mixte sollicitant l'accord des
assemblées des différentes nations de la
queue de l'Union européenne et pas
seulement une décision de la Commission
et enfin dernière revendication qui
surplombe toutes les autres sommes-nous
capables sur des enjeux aussi importants
qui relèvent de l’écocide et du respect
fondamentaux des droits humains d'avoir
une transparence des négociations c'est
de traiter et non seulement archaïque
sur le fond nous l'avons je crois
largement démontré il est totalement
archaïque sur la forme dans le sens où
il se fait dans l'opacité
et nous laissons dans une sorte du Brice
demain des industriels de la voiture ou
de l'aéronautique échanger leurs
capacité de développement dans des
accords ubuesques insensés qui ruineront
les chances de survie de l'humanité nous
avons au minimum besoin de cette
transparence nous avons besoin d'un
traité de nouvelles génération ou alors
ne devons pas de traiter du tout est-ce
que vous pouvez monsieur le ministre
parce que l'accord que nous avons qui
est transpartisan il est il vise
essentiellement à faire pression sur la
France pour qu'elle fasse pression sur
l'Europe est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
avec clarté parce que les signaux
étaient pour le moins ambigus ces
derniers temps quelle est la vision de
la France pour se traiter au nom du
respect de notre humanité commune de
notre santé commune des combats qui nous
rassemblent nous disons NON au Mercosur
aujourd'hui ne le faisons pas dans une
visée protectionniste nous le faisons
dans une visée de souveraineté solidaire
d'une France qui affirme ses valeurs des
valeurs universelles ses propres
intérêts qui rejoignent en l'occurrence
ceux de l'humanité êtes-vous capable
aujourd'hui sans aucune ambiguïté être
capable de rassurer non seulement le
monde paysan les ONG mais également des
députés qui aujourd'hui sur six groupes
différents ce sont engagés et se sont
rassemblés sur ce combat pour qu'enfin
nous ayons des garanties certaines que
nous allons éviter le pire et peut-être
dessiner une mondialisation plus
heureuse merci merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Luc la
mouillero pour le groupe horizon
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous
examinons aujourd'hui la proposition de
résolution relative à l'accord
commercial entre l'Union commerciale
l'Union européenne et le Mercosur
cette proposition est le fruit d'un
travail transpartisan et je tiens à
remercier mes collègues Pascal Lecan et
Frédéric descrosailles qui n'ont pas
ménagé leurs efforts pour aboutir à
cette proposition
l'examen de ce texte intervient un mois
avant la sommet de l'Union européenne
Amérique latine et Caraïbes qui se
tiendra à Bruxelles les 17 et 18 juillet
prochain ainsi avec l'adoption de cette
proposition de résolution nous
souhaitons envoyer un signal fort
auprès des institutions européennes
aucun nouveau traité de libre-échange ne
pourrait être soutenu par la France sans
l'intégration des demandes mentionnées
l'agriculture française fait notre
fierté
reconnu pour son excellence notre
production se distingue par sa fiabilité
grâce à la qualité notamment sanitaire
et environnementale de nos exploitations
et à la stabilité de leur rendement
si nous croyons dans le multi
latéralisme et dans la régulation du
commerce international aux accords de
libre-échange il est indéniable que
l'accord de principe entre l'Union
européenne et le Mercosur tel qu'il a
été envisagé en 2019 et loin d'être
satisfaisant au vu des gaz insuffisants
obtenus au cours des négociations
en effet
l'accord qui sera conclu et une fine et
ratifiée doit couvrir l'ensemble de nos
préoccupations et ne doit ne doit en
aucun cas défavoriser nos agriculteurs
nos partenaires commerciaux doivent être
soumis au même règle et obligations afin
de conclure des échanges équitables
il n'est pas acceptable d'importer du
soja
issu de la déforestation il n'est pas
acceptable d'importer des viandes
d'élevage qui ne sont pas soumis aux
mêmes normes sanitaire
en vous disant ceci je pense à tous mes
amis éleveurs aux règles sanitaires que
nous leur imposons et au nombre
d'efforts d'adaptation qu'ils doivent
réaliser
une concurrence déloyale ne serait pas
acceptable pour nos agriculture
ainsi avec mes collègues collègues nous
nous opposons à tout découpage en deux
parties de ce texte qui empêcherait
l'examen du volet commercial de cet
accord par les parlements nationaux des
États membres et donc nous donnerait par
le droit à la parole nous nous opposons
un accord qui ne respecte pas nos
engagements environnementaux sanitaires
et sociaux
pour que cet accord s'applique dans le
respect de nos valeurs nous demandons
une stricte application des normes
européennes pour les produits importés
cela implique une subordination des
clauses tarifaires préférentielles au
respect des normes européennes de
production environnementale sanitaire et
en matière de bien-être animal et au
respect de durabilité et de traçabilité
nous demandons la mise en place de
clauses miroir c'est-à-dire une
ressouris profité dans le respect des
normes de production dans les échanges
commerciaux afin de protéger notre
agriculture et nos agriculteurs et enfin
nous ne pouvons exposer le monde
agricole à deux possibles distorsion de
concurrence en l'absence de telles
clause suffisamment forte et contrôlée
nous demandons l'intégration de respect
de les accords de Paris de 2015 comme
close suspensive de l'accord nous
demandons que l'accord conclu dans son
intégralité soit soumis à la procédure
de ratification prévue pour les accords
mixtes et donc à un vote par les
parlements de notre pays
soucieux de protéger nos agriculteurs et
notre souveraineté alimentaire tout en
renforçant l'ambition de notre action en
matière agricole et environnementale le
groupe horizon et apparenté votre a en
faveur de cette proposition de
résolution
je vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Marie pochon pour
le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet accord tel qu'il a été conçu et
pensé ne peut pas être compatible avec
notre agenda climatique et de
biodiversité disait Emmanuel Macron en
2021 aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre
vous affirmez qu'il faut évidemment
conclure cet accord de libre-échange
avec Lula donc le retour de la
démocratie après bolsonaro autorise
évidemment la déforestation et les
accords injustes un changement de
gouvernement plus tard et c'est reparti
pour un tour voilà que wonderleyen et
Notre Ministre du Commerce extérieur
partent au Brésil tandis que l'Espagne
qui prendra la présidence de l'Union le
1er juillet souhaite que l'accord soit
signé d'ici la fin de l'année sans
hésitation nous écologiste appelons
évidemment à rejeter l'accord en l'état
et à l'avenir se dit a souvent été
qualifiée de viande contre-voiture en
libéralisant d'un côté le commerce de
boeuf de poulet de soja ou d'éthanol du
Mercosur vers l'Europe et de l'autre
celui des biens industriels des marchés
publics et des Services de l'Europe vers
le Mercosur autrement dit nous serons
submergés de produits agricoles
sud-américains et les peuples d'Amérique
latine verront leur service public
dégradé et être vendu à la découpe à des
multinationales prédatrices
mais cet accord est aussi un désastre
pour les éleveurs et agriculteurs des
deux côtés de l'Atlantique chers
collègues les importations de boeuf en
provenance du Mercosur pourrait
augmenter de près de 50%
. nous vous entendons chaque jour parler
souveraineté alimentaire sur tous les
bancs de cette émission comment
l'assurer face à un accord qui menace le
bien vivre de celles et ceux qui nous
nourrissent
car oui nous l'affirmons ici même à
condition sanitaire et environnementale
ce qui pour l'instant est loin d'être
une garantie le but premier de
l'agriculture n'est pas d'être
compétitive elle doit en priorité
s'attacher à nous nourrir dans les
meilleures conditions possibles pour les
paysans pour les citoyens et pour le
vivant alors que les incendies ravagent
la planète cet accord en l'état et à
l'avenir contribuera là aussi évidemment
à l'accélération du dérèglement
climatique à la déforestation à la
mondialisation de la malbouffe et à la
crise agricole rendez-vous compte
l'accord pourrait être suspendu si
l'Europe ne respecte pas son quota
d'importation de poules et congelés mais
le non-respect du climat et des droits
sociaux n'entraînerait aucune sanction
aucune suspension c'est choquant et
inacceptable pour pallier cette
anachronisme la Commission européenne
propose une lettre interprétative qui
aborderait les enjeux du climat et de la
déforestation mais sans aucune valeur
légale contraignante c'est une mascarade
un greenwashing affligeant
chers collègues l'Amazonie est à son
point de bascule et cet accord pourrait
entraîner une accélération de la
déforestation jusqu'à 25%. autant dire
un désastre en 2023 n'importe quel
accord devrait être assujetti à la
protection du climat et de la
biodiversité au respect de l'État de
droit des droits sociaux et humains tous
les accords devraient dans leur
négociation associer les citoyens et la
société civile pour que l'intérêt
général prévalent aux intérêts privés
l'accord UE Mercosur comme le tafta et
le CETA failli à ses deux principes
fondamentaux au sommet du G7 en 2019 le
président de la République avait indiqué
que la France ne pouvait pas soutenir
cet accord on dénonçant l'écocide en
cours dans la forêt amazonienne
qu'est-il arrivé quels sont les éléments
dont nous n'avons pas connaissance pour
que vous affirmiez aujourd'hui monsieur
le ministre que cet accord contient des
dispositions très favorables à nos
entreprises et que la France n'a jamais
été opposée à la signature de cet accord
monsieur le ministre c'est la
représentation nationale tout entière
qui vous le demande avec cette
résolution ou en sont les négociations
quel message monsieur le ministre
envoyez vous aux Français aux Européens
un moins d'un an des élections
européennes que l'Europe est un outil
destruction de notre agriculture que
l'Europe est un outil de concurrence
entre les peuples et les économies que
l'Europe n'est pas une démocratie mais
une lobby croise lobbycratie comme moi
comme les écologistes monsieur le
ministre vous dites aimer l'Europe
ne donnez pas du grain à moudre
populiste au septique au nationalisme
oui il aurait fallu que cette résolution
dise toute notre détermination à ne plus
laisser la mondialisation galopante
abîmée ce qui nous est commun de nos
acquis sociaux à la préservation du
vivant
il aurait fallu que cette résolution
dise toute notre détermination aussi à
faire primer la solidarité entre les
peuples sur les lois du marché oui cette
résolution devrait nous sortir de cette
opacité délétère des négociations elle
aurait dû inclure ses conséquences en
matière de droits humains et elle
devrait dire que la pleine application
des clauses miroir est aujourd'hui
impossible au vu des règles de l'OMC
mais cette résolution cependant une
chose essentielle qu'il faudra faire
avec l'Assemblée nationale et les
représentants de toutes les nations
européennes elle dit que nous pourrons
rejeter cet accord par cette résolution
transpartisane monsieur le ministre nous
vous le demandons pouvez-vous nous
confirmer que la représentation
nationale pourra débattre et voter tout
nouvel accord de commerce décidé à
l'échelle européenne et donc que vous
vous engagez pour le contre pardon pour
le splitzing pardonnez-moi et donc que
le splitting vous lui par la Commission
ne sera pas appliquée
pouvez-vous aussi vous engager enfin
apporter notre voix et celle des
millions de Français au Conseil européen
parce qu'il est temps que les règles du
commerce international bénéficient au
peuple du monde à la préservation de la
planète et non plus aux grandes firmes
multinationales nous écologistes
soutiendrons aujourd'hui cette
résolution et feront tout ce qui est en
notre pouvoir aux côtés des paysans des
peuples de part et d'autre de
l'Atlantique pour que demain cet accord
soit rejeté je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien
jumelle pour le groupe gauche-démocrate
et républicaine
ministre
collègue avec constance avec cohérence
le groupe communiste par la voix de
Jean-Paul Lecoq notamment c'est toujours
opposé au traité de libre-échange quel
qu'il soit
parce qu'ils abîment les vies qu'ils
abîment la planète
aujourd'hui l'agriculture française a
des allures de forteresse assiégées elle
est envahie du dehors par le dumpick
social et environnemental elle est
fragilisée à l'intérieur avec des
acteurs de moins en moins nombreux
fragilisés par les prix bas et un avenir
climatique un certain en l'espace de 20
ans nous avons laminé notre agriculture
à coup de libre-échange refusant de
protéger nos productions de la
concurrence déloyale la France a ainsi
capituler dans la bataille alimentaire
nous importations alimentaires ont
doublées entre 2000 et 2019 faisons
exploser notre dépendance sur un très
grand nombre de productions aujourd'hui
la France importe un poulet consommé sur
deux aujourd'hui la France importe deux
tiers de ses poissons consommés alors
qu'elles dispose du deuxième domaine
maritime mondial aujourd'hui la France
importe plus de la moitié des fruits et
légumes consommés bref aujourd'hui la
France n'assume plus sa souveraineté
alimentaire elle ne l'assume plus parce
qu'elle a renoncé à réguler les prix et
les rémunérations elle ne l'assume plus
parce qu'elle a préféré des prix bas
importé plutôt qu'une agriculture de
qualité une défense du pouvoir d'achat
et alors que ce constat devrait nous
obliger la France a poursuivi en
catimini d'une manière opaque sous les
présidents successives de Hollande et de
d'Emmanuel Macron un intense travail de
collaboration à la conclusion d'un
accord
UE Mercosur au mépris de tous les enjeux
climatiques alimentaires et sociaux
l'accord Mercosur se résume bien dans la
formule suivante des voitures contre les
vaches il risque de polluer nos
assiettes en échange de la promesse de
préserver nos parts de marché avec
l'Amérique du Sud dans certains secteurs
comme l'automobile cet acteur cet accord
se fera contre la santé des Français
aujourd'hui 27% des pesticides utilisés
par l'agriculture brésilienne sont
interdits au sein de l'Union européenne
cet accord sera également un coup
supplémentaire dans le cercueil du
climat la déferrostation va augmenter
sensiblement avec la ratification d'un
tel accord
entre 5 et 25% dans les premières années
alors même que les pays du Mercosur ont
une réserve inestimable en termes de
biodiversité cet accord est aussi en
passe d’être qui est en passe d’être
signé se fait au mépris de la plus
grande démocratie car nous nous pouvons
être convaincus d'une chose il est tout
sauf transparent comment expliquer sinon
toutes les manœuvres de la Commission
européenne pour séparer les différents
volets de l'accord afin de ne pas être
contrainte de devoir devant des
ratification des États membres on a
besoin d'être éclairés sur ce sujet
monsieur le ministre on a besoin d'être
rassuré sur le fait que l'interdiction
de séparation de splitage de l'accord
vous conduira
à solliciter la vie du Parlement mais
est-il possible dans le même temps de
compter sur le président de la
République j'ai dit ce matin en
conférence de presse souvent Emmanuel
Macron varie sur le Mercosur il a dit
tout et son contraire en fonction du
temps en fonction du vent en fonction
des interlocuteurs qu'il avait devant
eux les phrases ont été citées par mes
collègues je vous en ai parlé la
relecture tandis que les Français nous
demandent plus de protection pour notre
économie nous devons commencer par
protéger les mers de toutes les autres
l'agriculture oui certes ce texte il
nous avions tenu la plume aurait été
rédigé différemment parce qu'il est le
plus petit dénominateur commun il n'est
pas maximaliste il n'est même pas
contraignant comme toutes les PPR
d'ailleurs n'ont pas de valeur juridique
loin de proposer la fin d'une politique
des accords de libre-échange il
constitue cependant de notre point de
vue un symbole fort il m'a pas échappé
que les libéraux sont restés libéraux il
ne vous a pas échappé non plus que les
communistes notamment le groupe GDR va
rester va rester protecteur favorable
c'est ça qui protège un état qui prend
soin les communistes sont restés
communistes comment pourrait-il en être
autrement car oui il faut se réjouir
tout de même que l'ensemble de l'arc
politique y compris la majorité était
contrainte de concéder la nécessité de
conditionner nos importations au respect
de nos propres Scandes standards ce qui
est la moindre des choses qui soient
sociaux ou environnementaux il est
salvateur enfin de se retrouver tous
ensemble autour de l'idée que la
démocratie dans cette affaire n'est pas
négociable de ne sera pas négociable que
ce mauvais accord doit être soumis au
vote du Parlement et je vous annonce
d'ailleurs que nous quel que soit les
amoniations à la marge de cet accord
nous nous opposerons à cet accord sur le
Mercosur
vous verrez dans les expressions de la
gauche riche de sa diversité qu'il peut
y avoir des différents statiques mais
soyez assurés que nous sommes rassemblés
et unis sur l'idée que le libre-échange
un accord tel que le Mercosur fragilise
notre agriculture fragilise la planète
n'est bon pour personne c'est le sens
que nous donnerons c'est parce que nous
sommes contre le Mercosur que nous
voterons pour cette résolution
[Applaudissements]
indépendant outre-mer et territoire
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères où il
doit être par là monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues 20 ans après le début
des négociations l'Union européenne et
le Marcus ont signé un accord de
libre-échange en juin 2019 deux semaines
après la France signalait son refus de
signer la partie relative au commerce il
s'agissait alors de contester le peu de
considération pour le venez
environnemental notamment au regard de
la déforestation au Brésil au contraire
les piliers coopération et dialogues
politiques de la négociation non pas
soulevé de difficultés en 2020 le
rapport en bec rappelait que la corne
pouvait être signée en l'absence des
garanties relatives à la déforestation
importée et au respect de l'accord de
Paris
aujourd'hui c'est le secteur agricole
qui est vend debout contre cet accord
déloyal qui ne tient pas compte des
règles sanitaires à environnementales
européennes ni de notre conception du
bien-être animal la mise en oeuvre de
l'accord Mercosur permettra des gains de
pouvoir d'achat minime pour les
consommateurs européens c'est en réalité
surtout le secteur industriel qui
pourrait bénéficier de déboucher
significatif mais cet accord de
libre-échange aujourd'hui
est-il en phase avec les enjeux de notre
temps l'heure est à la relocalisation
des moyens de production à la
décarbonation et non à la déforestation
massive et à l'acaparement des terres
des peuples autochtones
enfin sur le plan sanitaire et
phytosanitaire l'accord avec le Mercosur
est une occasion manquée d'introduire
des exigences élevées dans les modes de
production de nos partenaires dès lors
deux pistes s'ouvrent à nous
premièrement il est nécessaire que la
France rappelle sa position actuelle et
disent clairement son opposition à toute
signature du texte actuel c'est l'objet
de la présente résolution que nous
voterons deuxièmement nous prenons acte
que de telles d'accord sont une
opportunité pour certaines entreprises
européennes d'exporter leur produit
ailleurs dans le monde de trouver de
nouveaux débouchés il faut cependant que
nos secteurs les plus fragiles ne soient
pas davantage menacés c'est en effet la
perte de compétence les faillites les
pertes d'emploi qui sont ici en jeu
voire la perte de nos souveraineté
alimentaire ce qui n'est pas rien dès
lors rappelons notre intérêt pour cet
accord à condition que trois critères
sont remplis d'abord les contrôles
doivent être nombreux effectifs et
contraignants la traçabilité des
produits et la qualité de l'information
sera mise à disposition du consommateur
final et cela doit être irréprochable je
me suis laissé dire que simplement 2% du
cheptel brésilien avait été contrôlé
donc 98% ne le sauraient pas quand vous
imaginez les contraintes que l'on peut
avoir en France par exemple et c'est
bien normal à la suite de la vache folle
par exemple et bien on peut s'étonner
effectivement de d'un certain laxisme
par ailleurs le respect de l'accord de
Paris doit être une condition
sinequanone de la signature et de la
mise en oeuvre de l'accord de
libre-échange toute l'application des
dispositions internationales doit être
évoluée à l'aune de cet accord s'il
s'avère que les partenaires américains
ne respectent plus leurs engagements
climatiques alors le volet commercial de
l'accord Mercosur devrait être surpendu
lorsque l'on voit la radicalité de sa
sein chartesse changement politique en
Amérique latine aujourd'hui on peut
trinquer enfin nos filières agricoles
doivent être protégées c'est-à-dire non
mis en concurrence avec une agriculture
qui n'a pas les mêmes normes sanitaires
les mêmes normes sociales et dont un
certain nombre de produits sont faits
avec des produits phytosanitaires qui
sont interdits en France donc on a ce
paradoxe ou quelque part on est prêt à
importer des produits que l'on
accepterait pas chez nous puisqu'on a
décidé d'interdire ces produits
phytosanitaires et donc il y a une
double injonction que nos paysans nous
rappellent comment peut-on répondez des
conditions environnementales de plus en
plus draconiennes et ça on en a besoin
pour notre environnement et de l'autre
côté les mettre en concurrence avec des
produits qui sont faits justement sans
ces conditions environnementales c'est
là où il y a une contradiction et qui
évidemment est souligné dans les
campagnes c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
évidemment contre cet accord vent debout
et que je peux les comprendre donc
évidemment ces questions agricoles sont
pour nous absolument essentiels parce
que c'est la vitalité effectivement de
notre agriculture donc de nos milieux
ruraux et c'est aussi notre souveraineté
alimentaire on l'a déjà vu par exemple
avec la viande de volaille plus de la
moitié enfin c'est 98% de les de la
viande de volaille consommée dans notre
restauration hors domicile qui est
importée vous voyez bien que là on a un
vrai problème
donc est-ce qu'il faut sacrifier
l'agriculture pour avoir quelques
produits industriels qui sont vendus je
ne le crois pas je ne le crois pas parce
que derrière on peut se passer de
beaucoup de choses on peut pas se passer
de manger et donc je crois que cette
souveraineté alimentaire on doit
vraiment faire extrêmement attention je
vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric
descrosailles pour le groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues beaucoup de choses ont
déjà été dites et je souscris à
l'essentiel de ce que nous avons entendu
depuis que cette discussion a démarré je
voudrais pour ma part chers collègues
monsieur le ministre
me rattacher à au contexte
des accords et du développement des
échanges internationaux dans lequel
s'inscrit cette discussion en fait nous
discutons d'un accord particulier dans
le cadre d'un multilatéralisme qui est à
l'agonie
je rappelle que au lendemain la Deuxième
Guerre mondiale il a été créé les quatre
grandes institutions de la
mondialisation telle que la connaissance
depuis la Banque Mondiale le FMI l'ONU
et le GAT le cycle de l'uruguayrand a
transformé le GAT en OMC lors de la
signature des accords de Marrakech en
1994 ce faisant l'agriculture qui
n'était pas à l'ordre du jour des
négociations internationales
est devenu l'un des sujets débattus dans
le cadre dans le cadre du
multilatéralisme et que s'est-il passé
dans le cadre de ce multilatéralisme
nouveau datant de 1994
Seattle premier échec
ensuite Hong Kong qu'est-ce qu'il
fallait après avoir deux échecs de suite
Cancun deuxième échec
des échecs qui ont signé un
multilatéralisme butant sur la question
agricole la question agricole n'est pas
rentrée dans la culture du développement
des échanges commerciaux tels qu'elle
avait été établie avec le gap DOA devait
durer trois ans
DOA est à l'agonie il n'y a plus de
multilatéralisme aujourd'hui qui servent
de cadre au développement des échanges
dont nous avons besoin
pourquoi parce que Marrakech a été
l'occasion de dire que toutes les formes
de soutien à l'agriculture partout dans
le monde avait vocation à être réduite
jusqu'à disparaître c'était une erreur
c'était une erreur grave et nous devons
en avoir conscience aujourd'hui à
l'heure où il s'agit de rebâtir un cadre
multilatéral nous avons besoin
d'échanges internationaux mais en
changeant de logiciels et en rompant
avec ce paradigme qui était une erreur
je rappelle que s'agissant de l'équation
agricole et alimentaire mondiale nous
avons aujourd'hui dans le monde environ
un milliard de personnes sous-alimentées
et en plus 2 milliards de personnes
malnutrit carence en macronutriments car
en micronutriments or 80% des affamés du
monde sont des paysans c'est-à-dire que
les besoins alimentaires mondiaux sont
massivement insolvables et c'est un
solvabilité est essentiellement paysanne
il n'est donc pas possible de signer des
accords d'échanges sans faire de
l'agriculture ce qu'elle est
c'est-à-dire l'une des cinq ressources
géostratégiques incomparable ne pouvant
pas être mis sur le même plan que
n'importe quel autre secteur de
l'économie l'eau l'alimentation
l'énergie une monnaie et des armes nous
parlons de l'alimentation nous parlons
aussi d'ailleurs de son impact sur l'eau
donc dans ce contexte il n'est pas
question de continuer à négocier des
accords sans faire de la question de
l'accès à l'alimentation de l'impact sur
les paysanneries les plus pauvres et les
plus précaires mais aussi la nôtre la
grille analyse qui permet de juger de la
pertinence de l'accord global
l'agriculture l'alimentation ne sont pas
un volet des accords que nous devons
négocier
c'est en ce sens là que nous au niveau
du groupe Renaissance en faisant appel à
la liberté de vote sur un texte qui est
compliqué dont je salue un cheminement
qui est inédit je me félicite de notre
capacité à trouver des objets politiques
qui ne sont prisonniers d'aucune
discipline partisane comme c'est le plus
souvent le cas c'est c'est le cas de
cette PPR
je dis simplement pour finir que il
s'agit j'ai parlé de paysanneries dans
le monde les plus précaires et de et de
paysanneries qui sont massivement qui
représentent les besoins alimentaires
massivement massivement insolvables mais
notre propre agriculture nous avons une
responsabilité pour la protéger pas
seulement pour nous-mêmes et pour notre
souveraineté mais dans le cadre d'une
sécurité alimentaire mondiale qui est
garantie par 5 zones de production dont
l'Europe de l'Ouest essentiellement la
France notre responsabilité de ne pas
porter atteindre à ce potentiel de
production puisque nous contribuons
directement à la stabilité géopolitique
du monde stabilité géopolitique dont je
vous rappelle que le GIEC dans cette
année rapports indique que elle est
sujette essentiellement à la rupture des
chaînes d'alimentation et de l'accès
d'alimentation c'est cela que nous
devons avoir à l'esprit et donc ne pas
ratifier cet accord en l'état et bien
développer des échanges développer ces
échanges dont nous avons besoin
maintenir notre responsabilité dans ce
cadre des échanges
écrire ce que doit être le nouveau cadre
multilatéral en faisant de l'agriculture
et de l'alimentation la grille d'analyse
qui permet de juger de la pertinence des
accords commerciaux
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric Falcon
pour le groupe rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
la présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues par cette proposition de
résolution vous confirmer ce que le
rassemblement national a toujours
dénoncé les dérives du mondialisme et
d'un libre-échange dérégulé mais s'il y
a quelques années vous nous accusiez de
jouer les Cassandre le réel vous
rattrape et nous donne raison nous
industries et nous agriculteurs font
face depuis des années à une concurrence
déloyale les uns ont dû mettre la clé
sous la porte les autres délocaliser
leur activité pour survivre ce que nous
déplorons n'est que la conséquence de
vos décisions passées sacrifions ainsi
l'environnement sur l’hôtel d'une
économie mondialisée profitant à
quelques financiers sans scrupules
depuis 2018 Marine Le Pen et le
rassemblement national alerte sur les
dangers du Mercosur les différents
salariales les écarts de revenus moyens
de protection sociale de normes
sanitaires ou encore les différences de
normes écologique créer les conditions
d'un homme ping social et
environnemental injuste
ce néolibéralisme imposé en marche
forcée par l'Union européenne détruit
notre agriculture
aujourd'hui en poursuivant votre fuite
en avant vous souhaitez limiter ces
dérives par des clauses miroirs L'Oréal
vous a rattrapé vous reconnaissez
implicitement la nécessité d'instaurer
un protectionnisme c'est un début mais
le courage de la cohérence écoutez nous
jusqu'au bout ne perdez pas de temps
pour la France et les Français adopter
le programme du rassemblement national
si les clauses Miwa miroir dont nous ne
connaissons pas l'étendue tente
d'insurer une forme de réciprocité il
est impossible de bâtir les fondements
d'une relation commerciale équilibrée
entre les pays présentant de telles
disparités de développement les revenus
nets des pays d'Amérique latine sont
environ cinq fois inférieures à celui de
l'Europe
un récent rapport du Sénat affirme que
Léo se décharge des producteurs et
surtranspositions et la fiscalité sont
la cause de la perte de notre
compétitivité toutes ces spécificités
françaises seront-elles intégrées dans
les causes miroirs non
chers collègues ne limitons pas
simplement la casse mais proposons
l'arène nette de cette folie tant qu'il
en est encore temps souvent ce qu'il
reste de notre agriculture de nos
petites et moyennes industries de
transformation renoncer simplement au
Mercosur l'intérêt français doit primer
sur une idéologie destructrice les
fédérations professionnelles ont tout
exprimé leur crainte la FNSEA manifeste
c'est plus vive inquiétudes en dénonçant
les ambitions sans actes dans
l'application de ces clauses miroirs
l'association nationale
interprofessionnelle du bétail et de la
viande sa larmes des importations de
produits agroalimentaires dans l'Union
européenne nous respectons pas les
normes sanitaires auxquelles sont
astreints nous élevage et nous
industries de transformation le cas du
Brésil était différent avec 30% de
substances autorisées mais interdites en
France le Mercosur s'est instauré une
concurrence déloyale par des produits de
moins bonne qualité et comment
pourrons-nous avoir la certitude que les
clauses miroir lutteront efficacement
contre cette concurrence malhonnête
comment sera contrôler l'application de
ces clauses à ce stade nous n'avons pas
de réponse claire
alors que notre économie est sans cesse
soumise au respect de nouvelles normes
énergétiques et environnementale imposé
de façon stricte et pénalisante pour
notre compétitivité l'importation de
produits agricoles depuis l'Amérique du
Sud est un non-sens absolu contrairement
aux affirmations mensongères de ce
gouvernement l'économie française sera
affaibli de ces six années de mandats
d'Emmanuel Macron l'inflation qui pèse
sur l'énergie et contre laquelle vous
refusez de vous attaquer en sortant la
France du marché européen de l'énergie
et en baissant les taxes fragilise la
compétitivité ne nous industries et de
notre agriculture avec la dette publique
la balance commerciale française qui
enregistre un déficit record et sans
doute l'un des points noirs du bilan
d'Emmanuel Macron le déficit commercial
s'élève aujourd'hui il y a plus de 160
milliards depuis 10 ans la balance
commerciale agricole ne cesse de se
dégrader le solde positif a été divisé
par deux elle a calmé observé avec la
récente inflation ne doit pas dissimuler
l'effondrement du volume de nos
exportations
la France importe désormais pour notre
consommation 28% des légumes 71% des
fruits 56% de la viande ovine 22% de la
viande bovine Emmanuel Macron affirmé en
2017 souhaitait une souveraineté
alimentaire force et de constater que la
majorité gouvernementale a accentué le
déclin de notre agriculture si c'était
résolution va dans le bon sens en
encourageant une inflexion
protectionniste elle amorce un
changement de paradigme dans la doctrine
du libre-échangisme devant des peuples
qui aspirent à retrouver leur
souveraineté si nous sommes favorables à
ces mesures miroirs nous militons avant
tout pour la non ratification de cet
accord commercial entre l'Union
européenne et le Mercosur dernier clou
planté dans le cercueil de l'agriculture
française je vous remercie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Arnaud Le Gal
pour le groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente chers collègues
cette proposition de résolution a un
mérite elle permet à l'Assemblée d'avoir
un débat sur un accord de libre-échange
négocié en cas de si mini depuis près de
30 ans
elle aurait pu se focaliser sur le rejet
de la méthode dite du découpage via
laquelle la Commission européenne en
tant qu'ont tourné le vote des Parlement
nationaux elle aurait ainsi servi de
points d'appui pour exiger que la
représentation nationale décide en
dernier ressort de l'adoption ou non de
cet accord mais voilà une fois passé un
exposé les motifs trompeurs
comme l'a dit notre collègue le camp
très honnêtement il apparaît que
l'objectif principal de cette religion
de nous faire accepter le principe même
de l'accord UE Mercosur dans une
déclinaison qui miracle
rejoint la communication d'Emmanuel
Macron qui fait mine de tout changer
pour que rien ne change
rappelons donc que cet accord est adopté
il freinera la diversification
économique nécessaire au pays du
Mercosur il favorisera un modèle
agricole extensif
voué à l'exportation au détriment des
cultures vivrières il aggravera sa cage
de la forêt amazonienne bien commun
essentiel à la vie humaine chez nous il
servira les intérêts de certains
entrepreneurs agricoles au détriment de
la masse des paysans et de notre
souveraineté alimentaire déjà fragilisée
par le sacrifice des productions les
moins compétitives à l'export donc d'une
polyculture qui faisait la force de
l'agriculture française on nous dit que
cet accord renforcera notre autonomie
stratégique en diversifiant les
approvisionnements au contraire il
aggravera la dépendance de l'Union
européenne au marché mondiaux des
matières premières connues pour leur
instabilité allons plus loin
à quoi rime de demander des garanties
écologiques alors que ces dispositifs
visent par nature a augmenté les flux
commerciaux de biocarburant boeuf soja
papier boissons etc et accélère à la
déforestation pour garantie sociale sont
tout aussi chimériques car c'est la
nature même du libre-échange que de
mettre en concurrence les producteurs
via une course au moins 10 ans sociale
et écologique et qu'attendre des clauses
miroirs aisément contournables elle
repose sur l'idée que notre modèle
européen serait vertueux c'est l'oublier
un peu vite qu'au saint même de l'Union
européenne le dumping social et
écologique et de mise
ces postuler également que nous
disposons en l'état des moyens de
contrôle nécessaire alors que des
décennies de néolibéralisme ont
gravement affaibli nos services
douaniers
en définitive cette proposition de
résolution offre au gouvernement une
porte de sortie
lorsqu'il a détourné la présidence
française de l'Union européenne au
service de sa campagne Emmanuel Macron
avertir refusait de signer l'accord
la position a depuis évolué
la finalité est claire énoncée sans
phare par le ministre chargé du Commerce
extérieur je cite nous n'avons jamais
été opposé à la signature de cet accord
il faut évidemment conclure de
préférence après les élections
européennes pensaient-ils sûrement sans
le dire nous ne sommes pas d'accord le
libre-échangisme est d'abord une
politique de classe quelques-uns ont à y
gagner beaucoup pour taillis perdre les
opinions publiques l'ont compris de même
que les 400 associations et syndicats
qui de part et d'autre de l'Atlantique
s'opposent à l'accord parmi elles la
Confédération paysanne qui n'a pas pu
participer malgré sa demande à la
conférence de presse de présentation de
cette résolution
entendons ces lanceurs d'alerte comment
croire encore au doux commerces et au
mondialisation et aux vertus d'une
mondialisation heureuse profitant à tous
comme si l'explosion des déséquilibres
commerciaux ne participe pas de
l'instabilité structurelle des économies
comme si la pandémine n'avait pas eu
lieu comme si la crise écologique
n'était pas là comme si nous
n'assistions pas au spectacle une infime
minorité se servant des pénuries
aggravés voire provoquer par les
mécanismes des marchés pour accroître
les profits
l'adoption de l'accord UE merco sur
relancera la machine folle quelle
nouvelle accord de libre-échange nous
sera servi dans la foulée au terme d'une
gestation opaque celui avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande ou avec l'Australie
avec l'Inde la Thaïlande ou avec le
Kenya
ces grands accords de libre-échange
pensez dans les années 90 compte parmi
les résidus d'une phase révolue de la
mondialisation entendez le
libre-échangisme est obsolète tous ces
dispositifs néfastes et destructeurs ont
fait leur temps et un jeu de
greenwashing ne suffira pas à leur
donner une nouvelle jeunesse nous ne
pouvons donc pas apporter notre soutien
à ce texte une autre organisation du
commerce international est possible et
nécessaire elle subordonnerait les
échanges des objectifs politiques
économiques et sociaux supérieures tous
nos comptes de l'intérêt social et
écologique du plus grand nombre et non
des profits de quelques-uns elle
interdirait les déséquilibres abyssaux
des échanges commerciaux comme on l'a
fait par le passé et ça n'empêchait pas
qu'il y avait du commerce international
promouvoir la négociation de telles
règles dans le cadre de ce que nous
appelons pour notre part à
protectionnisme solidaire est une
condition nécessaire pour répondre aux
immenses des filles nationaux et
mondiaux qui sont devant nous pour merci
très bon merci
la parole est à Monsieur Julien di pour
le groupe les républicains
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs la présidente de la Commission
européenne était hier au Brésil le
président Lula rencontre Emmanuel Macron
le 22 juin et vous-même monsieur le
ministre vous avez récemment déclaré en
anglais dans la pression européenne
j'ouvre les guillemets l'accord avec le
mercu sur contient des dispositions très
favorables à nos entreprises c'est
pourquoi nous n'avons jamais été opposé
à ces réformes fin de citation moi je
crois monsieur le ministre que cet
accord est très défavorable aux
agriculteurs éleveur européen et
défavorable à l'avenir de notre planète
chaque rapprochement de ce type entre la
France et les quatre pays du Mercosur
est un coup de couteau supplémentaire
dans le cœur de notre agriculture cette
nouvelle réforme de traiter hors sol
vient s'ajouter aux multiples décisions
qui entérinent la France dans une
politique autodestructrice de sa
souveraineté agricole beaucoup on
considérait que l'autonomie alimentaire
de la France était un acquis mais le
paradigme m'a bien changé aujourd'hui la
ratification de l'accord entre l'Union
européenne et le Mercosur présenterait
un risque immense pour les agriculteurs
et finirait d'achever notre modèle
français il encouragerait l'importation
de produits agricoles hors standard de
production européen donnant alors un
avantage considérable au pays du
Mercosur les propos du ministre Bruno Le
Maire le 17 mai dernier l'encourage
d'ailleurs pas l'élevage français il
vante la production des steaks végétaux
il dénonce les éleveurs français bref en
tantième ministre et culture il mord la
main qui la nourrit la Cour des comptes
s'empresse aussitôt d'achever la filière
bovine en appelant dans son dernier
rapport à réduire l'élevage français
ce ne sont pas des recommandations mais
une décapitalisation très forte de
l'élevage français et de notre
souveraineté on ne demande pas la Cour
des comptes de compter les bouses des
vaches mais de conseiller le
gouvernement sur une stratégie de
réduction de la dette et c'est déjà pas
si mal monsieur le ministre vous devez
vous-même dénoncer ses actes notre
agriculture est à l'agonie nos éleveurs
sont démunis mais rien n'est entrepris
cet accord est comparable au CETA adopté
de justesse en France le 23 juillet 2019
par 266 voix pour et 213 voies contre
l'application est de fait provisoire
tant que le Sénat ne s'est pas prononcé
qu'attendons donc le gouvernement pour
demander l'inscription de l'examen du
CETA à l'ordre du jour du Sénat chaque
jour l'agriculture française est
attaquée par les biens pensants il s'en
prennent à une filière respectueuse
exigeante mais affaiblie car ils sont
incapables de voir plus loin que le bout
de leur nez
le soulèvement de la terre qui a détruit
sa souligne le week-end dernier les
cultures sans pesticides de maraîcher
note agriculture ne peut pas être
bafouée jour après jour par cette bande
de punk à chien mêlé à des 68 heures
nostalgiques
regardez donc au Brésil les bêtes sont
parqués dans 12 mètres carrés par tête
entre les fidelots Brésiliens et Martine
à la ferme il y a l'agriculture
française que nous devons protéger
aujourd'hui
cette ratification en très très
entraînerait une concurrence déloyale
subie par nos éleveurs européens
l'entrée
de viande produite à bas coût
bénéficions d'une réduction de droits de
douane et de contingent tarifaire ne
pourrait qu'empirer la situation aussi
aussi les antibiotiques de croissance
sont autorisés en Amérique du Sud ainsi
que de nombreux produits phytosanitaires
dont l'usage était interdit dans l'Union
européenne 27% des ingrédients actifs
utilisés au Brésil était interdit en
2020 au sein de l'UE sur trois ans près
de 1200 nouveaux pesticides ont
d'ailleurs été autorisés au Brésil dont
193 contenant des substances interdites
dans l'UE les instances européennes ont
relevé de nombreuses défaillances dans
les contrôles sanitaires effectués dans
plusieurs pays du Mercosur or l'accord
prévoit des mesures d'allègement des
contrôles sanitaires cela en dépit des
centres des scandales répétitions qui
ont notamment secoué le Brésil et par
ailleurs mis en lumière un système de
contrôle corrompu la symétrie dans les
conditions de production à l'absence de
mesure miroir en vigueur conduirait une
situation de concurrence déloyale enfin
cet accord est absolument incompatible
avec l'urgence climatique la forêt
amazonienne entrerait alors davantage
dans un processus de déforestation
colossale il y aurait des conséquences
dramatiques sur le climat la
biodiversité et bien sûr l'agriculteurs
par conséquent il est urgence sauvé la
filière agricole avec trois priorités
que nous devons fixer garantit un jeu
commerciale à armes égales avec nos
partenaires européens internationaux
pour que les produits importés soit
soumis au même règle que les productions
en France faites en France 2 exiger la
réciprocité pour assurer l'équité du jeu
concurrentiel 3 donnez les moyens
financiers et matériels agriculteurs
pour anticiper les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique le traité de
libre-échange entre l'Union européenne
et Mercure étant absolument contraire à
ces trois objectifs le groupe LR demande
à Roger ferme et définitif de toute
ratification et votera donc pour cette
proposition de résolution pour préserver
plus que jamais le système de production
française je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues cette
proposition de résolution est la
bienvenue mais n'est-elle pas la Libye
d'un double jeu voilà la vraie question
le président de la République sur cet
accord a dit tout et son contraire et
les récentes déclarations du
gouvernement ne peuvent que nous
inquiéter
n'oubliez pas que vous avez laissé faire
la Commission de Bruxelles qui avec son
approche dogmatique du libre-échange
intégrale assigner ce texte qui ne
répond ni aux intérêts de la France ni
aux intérêts des pays du Mercosur tout
d'abord on l'a dit je vais pas reprendre
en augmentant les quotas d'importation
sans droit de douane
99000 tonnes de viande bovine 180000
tonnes de volaille 26000 tonnes de
viande porcine c'est un accord
suicidaire pour notre agriculture
l'agriculture du Mercosur n’étant pas
assujetti aux normes européennes
antibiotiques pesticides interdit chez
nous la concurrence sera obligatoirement
déloyale nos agriculteurs ne pouvant pas
s'aligner sur les prix des agriculteurs
du Mercosur
mais cet accord est aussi dangereux pour
les nations du Mercosur et comme
président du groupe d'amitié
France-Brésil je peux vous dire que
beaucoup au Brésil sont inquiets de la
suppression des droits de douane sur
l'industrie qui va déstabiliser leur
industrie le président Lula d'ailleurs
quand il était dans l'opposition avait
dénoncé cet accord enfin enfin cet
accord initié en 2000 vous l'avez tous
dit ne prend pas en compte le changement
d'époque et la préoccupation
environnementale mondiale ce n'est pas
en spécialisant les continents
l'agrobusiness pour le Mercosur
l'industrie pour l'Allemagne que l'on
réduire à l'effet de serre des
transports de marchandises entre
continents et que l'on permettra aux
différents pays un développement
diversifié et donc harmonieux
une fois de plus
l'hypocrisie de la Commission de
Bruxelles est insupportable comment
peut-elle oser présenter cet accord
comme je cite un engagement à lutter
contre la déforestation alors que ce
texte si par malheur il était approuvé
favoriserait encore plus la
spécialisation agricole du Brésil dans
le libre-échange mondial et conduirait
donc à une augmentation de la production
intensive de soja et donc à davantage de
déforestation en Amazonie c'est un fait
évident de même quel incohérence à
interdire la production la consommation
en Europe de certains pesticides pour
autoriser les entreprises chimiques
notamment allemandes à les revendre en
Amérique du Sud pour les retrouver enfin
dans les produits que nous allions
importer d'Amérique du Sud quel
incohérence voilà pourquoi la France
doit impérativement mettre son veto
à cet accord non transparent refusé
monsieur le ministre en commission des
affaires étrangères il est à peu près un
mois vous n'avez pas été très clair
allez-vous refuser clairement la
scission de la corde c'est-à-dire éviter
que cet accord comme pour le Chili ou
pour le CETA puisse s'appliquer sans
ratification parlementaire allez-vous
enfin avoir une vraie politique avec
l'Amérique du Sud car je rappelle à mes
chers collègues que tous les présidents
de la République ont choyé ce continent
de la célèbre tournée du général de
Gaulle mais qu'il n'y a qu'un seul
président de la République qui n'a
jamais été en Amérique du Sud excepté un
passage de deux jours à Buenos Aires
pour le sommet du G20 c'est Emmanuel
Macron deux jours en six ans et je peux
vous le dire que nos concurrents
allemands anglais portugais espagnol ne
se gêne pas pour pour récupérer nos
positions dans ce magnifique continent
où nous avons des intérêts communs eu
des intérêts culturels économiques alors
la vraie question plutôt que des décès
madame vanderleyen faire ses affaires en
Amérique du Sud et défendent les
intérêts de l'industrie allemande au
détriment de l'agriculture française la
vraie question monsieur le ministre
c'est est-ce que votre gouvernement aura
le courage d'être cohérent c'est-à-dire
le courage au mois de juillet lors du
sommet à dire clairement non véto pour
l'intérêt de l'agriculture pour
l'intérêt de la planète pour une
nouvelle idée du libre-échange qui
respecte les peuples et qui respectent
l'équilibre du monde
je vous remercie la discussion générale
est close la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier belge qui ministre délégué
des Français de l'étranger
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
d'abord je voudrais vous remercier
d'avoir inscrit cette proposition de
résolution à l'ordre du jour
elle nous permet en réalité d'avoir un
débat au-delà de la question même de
l'accord sur le Mercosur sur la question
de la politique commerciale voire même
sur la question du commerce
international lui-même parce que dans ce
que j'ai entendu cet après-midi qui a
venant de la gauche et même de l'extrême
droite de cette émission
c'est en réalité une remise en cause du
commerce international alors disons-le
tout de suite mesdames et messieurs les
députés qui a le protectionnisme
solidaire dont vous parlez
c'est mortifères pour notre économie
c'est mortifères pour notre économie et
je vais vous dire pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
pour deux raisons parce que les
murailles que vous voulez construire
autour de notre pays
d'abord chez murailles empêcheront
peut-être s'il vous plaît les produits
des autres de sortie des produits des
autres d'entrées dans notre pays
je
note d'abord qu'un certain nombre de
produits ne sont pas produits en France
et ne le seront jamais si demain nous
empêchons les importations sur le
pétrole il n'y a plus mesdames et
messieurs d'essence à la pompe c'est une
réalité
deuxièmement nous avons en économiste
qu'on appelle des avantages comparatifs
c'est à dire qu'il est plus facile et
moins cher de produire certains produits
dans certains pays que dans d'autres et
ses avantages comparatifs ont permis au
cours des 30 40 dernières années a
beaucoup de ménages français de
s'équiper notamment de bien
d'équipements qu'ils ont acheté bien
moins cher sur les marchés en 1980 il
fallait à peu près un mois de salaire
pour s'acheter un téléviseur à moi de
salaire médian français il en faut
aujourd'hui moins d'une semaine
ces prix ont permis
le ménage français de s'équiper à
moindre prix ce qui veut dire a
contrario que votre protectionnisme
solidaire c'est en réalité une inflation
imposée au ménage français qui a qui
verront leur pouvoir d'achat fortement
réduits
il faut le dire
deuxièmement quand on construit des
murailles autour d'un pays pour empêcher
les produits des autres de rentrer et
bien c'est même murailles mesdames et
messieurs les députés empêche nos
produits de sortie et donc vous
pénalisez une grande partie des
entreprises françaises les grandes
entreprises mais aussi les PME PMI qui
sont exportatrices et c'est vrai
également et c'est vrai également pour
l'agriculture française car mesdames et
messieurs un certain nombre de grande
filière française je pense au va et
spiritueux je pense également
aux céréales je pense à la filière
laitière 40% d'exportation sur la
filière laitière je pense également à la
filière porcine qui sont toutes des
filières largement excédentaires d'un
point de vue exportateur d'ailleurs j'en
veux pour preuve que lors du dernier
accord de libre-échange que nous avons
lancé en l'occurrence le CETA avec le
Canada on nous avait annoncé c'était les
mêmes mots d'ailleurs sur les bancs du
rassemblement national on nous avait dit
c'est le dernier clou enfoncé dans le
cercueil de la filière bovine française
nous avons aujourd'hui plus de 30%
d'exportation sur l'agriculture nous
exportons nous exportons trois fois plus
de bœuf français au Canada que nous
n’importe-t-on de bœuf canadien en
France c'est la réalité et ce sont les
chiffres
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que cela veut dire
mesdames et messieurs les députés que
nous avons
besoin d'un libre-échange sans limite la
réponse
la réponse est non la réponse est NON et
oui qui a au cours des dernières
décennies au cours des dernières
décennies le libre-échange a pu sur
certaines sur certains produits
notamment et avec certaines parties du
monde engendrer un dumping social
environnemental sanitaire qui n'est pas
favorable aux consommateurs français ni
aux consommateurs européens et c'est la
raison pour laquelle et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous menons depuis
quelques années il y a une révolution
dans le cadre de la politique
commerciale
ça devrait vous faire plaisir sur les
bancs de la gauche une révolution en
voici une dans la politique commerciale
en quoi consiste en quoi consiste cette
révolution dans la politique commerciale
et bien elle consiste à remettre
l'humain et la planète au cœur de notre
politique commerciale l'humain et la
planète
l'humain d'abord avec l'introduction des
conventions de l'Organisation
internationale du Travail luttant contre
le travail forcé luttant contre le
travail des enfants avec des mécanismes
de sanction dans les traités
l'humain c'est encore les mesures miroir
que nous votons aujourd'hui à la fois
pour protéger le consommateur contre les
pesticides contre les antibiotiques de
croissance contre les néonicotinoïdes
la planète
la planète c'est quoi la planète c'est
le respect également des normes
sanitaires et environnementales de
l'Union européenne c'est le règlement
contre la déforestation chez les acteurs
de Paris comme close obligatoire dans
les traités voilà voilà la révolution
que nous menons dans le cadre de la
politique commerciale pour le respect de
l'humain et de la planète dans le sens
d'une plus grande responsabilité mais
surtout d'une vraie réciprocité entre
les différents partenaires de l'échange
alors alors venant au mercosour si
jamais si jamais la question si jamais
la question devait vous intéresser qui a
puisque depuis 7 minutes 07 vous ne
faites que hurler sur les bancs à
l'extrême gauche comme à l'extrême
droite
sans aucun respect sans aucun risque
social souligné puisque mesdames et
messieurs je vous ai écouté
religieusement sur les bancs sans
intervenir et depuis que j'ai pris la
parole vous votifierez dans l'hémicycle
puisque visiblement le fond du sujet de
vous intéresse pas puisque vous êtes pas
principe contre tout échange économique
la parole est à monsieur le ministre je
vous remercie s'il vous plaît d'être
plus calme dans l'intérêt de tous s'il
vous plaît monsieur le ministre
s'exprime je vous remercie
alors parlons même au milieu des
vociférations alors parlons du Mercosur
le Mercosur d'abord c'est un ensemble de
quatre états le Brésil l'Argentine
l'Uruguay et le Paraguay avec lequel
nous entretenons de bonnes relations
et nous avons maintenant depuis 23 ans
dénégociations avec le Mercosur
en 2019 un accord a été présenté sur le
bureau du Conseil européen
la France a pris ses responsabilités et
elle a dit que cet accord était
inacceptable en l'état il était
inacceptable en l'état parce qu'il était
profondément contraire à ce que nous
souhaitons dans cette révolution de la
politique commerciale c'est-à-dire la
prise en compte de l'humain et de la
planète et c'est la raison pour laquelle
mesdames et messieurs à la demande du
Président de la République et nous avons
ce même discours d'où le portons dans
tous les cercles et j'y reviendrai dans
un instant nous avons posé nous avons
posé trois conditions trois conditions à
la possibilité d'une conclusion d'un
accord avec les pays du Mercosur la
première condition c'est la prise en
compte des accords de Paris comme close
essentielle de l'accord commercial
c'est-à-dire que si les acteurs de Paris
ne sont pas respectés si l'un des États
du Mercosur sont retirés alors l'accord
tomberait automatiquement la deuxième
condition
la deuxième condition c'est la prise en
compte
d'énormes sanitaires et
environnementales de l'Union européenne
les fameuses mesures miroir pour faire
en sorte que les règles qui sont
imposées à nos producteurs en France
dans le secteur agricole comme dans
d'autres secteurs soit imposer également
au producteurs des pays dans lesquels
nous apporterions des marchandises
c'est ça les mesures miroir c'est ce que
nous souhaitons et nous avons été très
clairs et nous avons rajouté à cela un
certain nombre d'éléments notamment le
règlement contre la déforestation qui
est évidemment la pierre angulaire de
notre politique vis-à-vis des états du
Mercosur en disant qu'il était hors de
question de pouvoir importer quelques
produits que ce soit y compris dans le
domaine alimentaire qui soit produit sur
la déforestation et je le dis pas
simplement de l'Amazonie mais également
de la forêt atlantique ou d'autres
forêts qui sont aujourd'hui dans les
pays du Mercosur
et enfin la troisième condition la
troisième condition c'est qu'il y ait
dans cet accord des mécanismes de
sanction
claire opérationnel qui soit évidemment
en vigueur au moment où l'accord
lui-même entrera en vigueur voici trois
conditions qui sont extrêmement claires
et que nous avons posé sur la table
ces conditions-là ces conditions-là nous
les avons porté à la fois au Conseil des
Ministres de l'Union européenne auprès
de la Commission européenne mais
également auprès des autorités
brésiliennes et c'est exactement le
discours que j'ai tenu la semaine
dernière
à Brasilia auprès des autorités
brésiliennes il n'y a aucune ambiguïté
il n'y a aucun double discours les
conditions de la France sont extrêmement
claires et c'est à l'aune de ces
conditions et à l'aune seulement de ces
conditions dans les négociations qui se
passent en ce moment entre la Commission
européenne et les du Mercosur que nous
déciderons s'il y a lieu ou pas de
pouvoir accepter un accord si un tel
instrument additionnel devait être
conclu la réalité mesdames et messieurs
c'est que sur ce projet de résolution
nous en remettons évidemment à la
sagesse de votre assemblée mais je dois
considérer néanmoins que entre le fond
de la résolution et la position du
gouvernement il y a une très forte
convergence mesdames et messieurs les
députés je vous remercie je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
alors je vous rappelle tout de même
qu'avant de passer au vote il y a les
explications de vote
donc nous allons les commencer je
rappelle le principe s'il vous plaît 5
minutes avec un orateur par groupe avant
de démarrer sur le vote de la
proposition de résolution je suis saisie
par plusieurs groupes la France
insoumise le groupe les républicains le
groupe démocrate le groupe socialiste
d'une demande de scrutin public le
scrutin est annoncé dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale
nous démarrons donc les explications de
vote avec Monsieur le camp pour le
groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente
alors c'est l'heure de vérité pour
chacun d'entre nous au moment de voter
ce texte d'un côté la préservation de
l'environnement et de la forêt
amazonienne de l'autre la protection de
nos éleveurs ces deux seules
préoccupations majeures s'impose à nous
à nous tous et nous oblige
je m'adressais ici au collègue insoumis
qui veulent voter contre cette
résolution
ce sera une nouvelle démonstration que
vous ne faites pas partie de l'axe
républicain
et et
de vos incohérences
et de vos incohérences
en refusant le fruit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas vu je vais me renseigner je
me renseigne monsieur balano
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
FFRE une suspension de sens de deux
minutes monsieur le camp allez-y
merci madame la Présidente en refusant
le fruit d'un compromis transpartisan
[Musique]
travailler entre autres
compromis transpartisan travailler entre
autres avec l'un des plus engagés des
vôtres François Ruffin
en refusant d'envoyer à nos partenaires
de l'Union européenne un signal d'autant
plus fort qu'il aurait été unanime
vous tombez encore toujours dans
l'opposition systématique
[Musique]
vous affaiblissez un peu plus encore la
voix de la France mais c'est surtout la
vôtre qui devient inaudible
alors alors chers collègues insoumis
alors
on n'a pas encore voté il est pas trop
tard
un vote contre serait donc incohérent et
contraire à l'engagement que nous
portons tous pour protéger avec exigence
la biodiversité et la forêt en
particulier
[Musique]
je sais que nous avons tous en partage
c'est sympa de travailler dans cette
ambiance je vous ai écouté vous pouvez
m'écouter ça devient complètement fou
je sais que nous avons tous en partage
une alimentation de qualité avec une
traçabilité incontestable et incontesté
votez contre ce texte serait un coup
majeur porté à l'agriculture française
dont nous sommes les garants garant des
standards et d'une production de qualité
alors alors chers collègues je n'ose
imaginer un instant des votes contraires
qui seraient un signal désastreux pour
nos agriculteurs et un pied de nez à
l'environnement le groupe démocrate
votre a donc bien évidemment pour cette
résolution
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas
je sais pas par quel magie
cette résolution qui était censée
dénoncer l'ambiguïté du gouvernement de
l'exécutif et du président de la
République deviendrait par elle-même une
forme d'ambiguïté je ne sais pas par
quelle magie ce que je veux rappeler
très simplement pour avoir été au cœur
au nom des socialistes de la
construction de cet arc contre le
Mercosur qui les fondé sur des valeurs
très claires la dignité des travailleurs
de la terre de chaque côté de
l'Atlantique la défense avec la même
énergie de l'Amazonie et des herbages du
Massif Central la défense de notre
sécurité alimentaire collective qui
supposera qu'on lutte contre
l'accaparement des terres qu'on la
partage et qu'on installe partout des
paysans aux revenus dignes pour dire ici
comme jamais que jamais l'alimentation
la nourriture ne seront une marchandise
comme les autres que nous devons
coopérer que nous devons inventer des
coopérations multiples puisque la seule
condition à laquelle 10 milliards
d'individus vivront dignement en 2050
donc c'est fini le libre nous devons
inventer le juste échange et c'est ce
que dit très clairement cette résolution
cette résolution qui l'accomplisse de
tous les libéraux
l'ultra-libéralisme nous nourrit l'île
la dérive illibéraliste il libéral
pardon qui dénonce aujourd'hui l'agence
de sécurité sanitaire ou les règlements
européens ne devons-nous méfier de cette
grave dérive de Don réaffirmer les
valeurs qui sont les nôtres celle de la
régulation du juste commerce du commerce
équitable c'est pour ça que les
socialistes sont engagés qui sont
engagés dans cette résolution je leur
affirmé la clarté de Somme au cœur d'un
rassemblement qui défend dans la
mondialisation une souveraineté
solidaire
[Musique]
la parole est à Monsieur Bayou pour le
groupe écologiste
merci merci madame la Présidente écoutez
d'abord un mot liminaire pour le
collègue Lecan qui voit dans le vote de
cette résolution le choix du camp
républicain ou non vraiment je pense que
c'est pas digne en fait voilà votre
comportement et j'ose le mot c'est pas
digne votre comportement sectaire et
d'instrumentalisation d'un sujet majeur
tout ça pour jeter l'eau propre sur nos
collègues insoumis c'est indigne en fait
voilà tout simplement et c'est pas sur
le choix d'une résolution qu'on fait
partie ou non de l'arc républicain et
c'est encore moins à vous de le décider
ça c'est pour le premier point pour le
deuxième point
si on avait des doutes sur la nécessité
de voter pour cette résolution et bien
le laïus pénible du ministre fini de
convaincre vraiment si vous aviez des
doutes à écouter le ministre il faut
voter cette résolution il y a au moins
trois enjeux et avec les députés
écologistes on fait notre les arguments
des députés écologistes européens un
enjeu évidemment d'abord environnemental
et climat
c'est une catastrophe cet accord pour le
climat c'est une catastrophe pour la
biodiversité et c'est une catastrophe
pour notre agriculture un enjeu social
qui rejoint les aspects d'agriculture
ici mais carrément de droits humains
dans toute l'Amérique du Sud et puis un
enjeu et là collègue vous êtes concerné
un enjeu démocratique de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement et par cette
résolution ici nous affirmons que nous
ne voulons pas nous voir dépossédés de
ce contrôle c'est-à-dire la ratification
et donc en vérité ça doit nous
rassembler si vous avez la confiance si
vous portez confiance dans ce
gouvernement c'est pas mon cas et
d'ailleurs il nous a pas demandé la
confiance mais si vous avez confiance
dans ce gouvernement votez pour ratifier
ce texte et si vous n'avez pas confiance
comme nous votez pour pouvoir ne pas
ratifier ce texte et donc j'en finis
c'est parce que nous sommes
résolument contre le narcosur que nous
voterons cette résolution
je vous remercie
la parole est la parole est à Monsieur
Benoît pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente simplement au
nom du groupe horizon et apparenté
naturellement nous allons voter cette
résolution qui a été construite par les
représentants de 9 groupes politiques et
il s'agit là d'affirmer et bien en
France dans le dans la construction
européenne la question de la réciprocité
et la France qui reste naturellement
ouverte au monde concernant les échanges
mais on ne peut échanger que dans le cas
des respects comme ça a été dit par
plusieurs orateurs notamment Dominique
Pottier le respect des femmes et des
hommes qui produisent le respect des
conditions animales et le respect de
l'environnement c'est à dire que nous
voulons des relations qui puissent durer
c'est ce qu'on appelle maintenant le
développement durable mais c'est quelque
chose que nous devons du point de vue
politique réaffirmé du point depuis le
niveau local et territorial jusqu'au
niveau national notamment dans le cas de
la construction de l'Union europ chaîne
et il est bien qu'à notamment comme la
France soit faire de lance dans les
exigences posées à nos interlocuteurs
internationaux et c'est pour ça que nous
voterons cette résolution je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur jumelles pour
le groupe Go géocrate et républicaine
peut-être présidente rappeler deux trois
principes simples
d'abord sans caractère transpartisan
pas de PPR
et sans PPR pas une minute de débat sur
le Mercosur peut-être que cela aurait
arrangé le trait libéral ministre et
donc on peut se satisfaire que cette
démarche transpartisane est contraint le
ministre le gouvernement a parlé de
négociation qu'il aurait préféré
réaliser en catimini dans les couloirs
de Bruxelles premier élément
deuxième élément je le dis à mon
collègue Lecan que je trouvais plutôt
sympa au téléphone plutôt ouvert ne vous
perdez pas dans des postures
politiciennes sur des sujets qui
méritent mieux ne croyez pas qu'en
tirant sur notre propre camp vous allez
nous diviser lorsqu'on tire sur notre
propre camp on est uni comme à bord
comme on dit à Dieppe ne tombez pas dans
les postures politiciennes
je veux dire au ministre que il aurait
pu nous éviter de parler parce que il
est un mauvais ambassadeur de la PPR qui
est soumise au vote aujourd'hui
j'ai expliqué au nom du groupe des
parlementaires communistes à quel point
le vote sur cette proposition de
résolution
signifiait pour nous la réaffirmation de
notre opposition à ce mauvais traité qui
comme l'a très bien dit Dominique potier
porte atteinte à la dignité des paysans
porte atteinte à la biodiversité de
notre planète notamment aux forêts de
part et d'autre de nos pays et porte
atteinte à notre souveraineté
alimentaire dans notre dans la durée je
redis que c'est parce que nous sommes
contre le Mercosur que nous voterons
à quelques unités près
favorables à la proposition
de résolution mais je veux avec les
quelques minutes qui me restent
en profiter pour vous reposer une
question parce que j'ai l'impression que
vous n'avez pas lu la résolution
monsieur le ministre
dans la résolution dans le dernier
paragraphe de la résolution il est écrit
la présente proposition de résolution
vise ainsi à demander au gouvernement à
marquer son refus quant à la signature
de l'accord entre l'Union européenne et
le merco sur quelques conclus en 2019 et
à toute tentative de découpage du
diaccord par la Commission européenne
vous n'avez pas répondu sur le splitage
vous nous avez pas répondu sur
l'obligation que vous avez à rendre
compte au Parlement de toutes velléité
de spidage de cet accord qui le ferait
devenir à nos yeux encore plus mortifère
encore plus mortifère voilà ce que
m'inspire le débat qui vient de se poser
je redis qu'il n'y aurait pas à gauche
des ventres mous des ventres durs des
courageux des pas courageux on est tous
alignés sur le fait que le libre-échange
fait mal aux vies fait mal à la planète
et est mauvais pour les acteurs qui
assurent la souveraineté alimentaire on
peut avoir des différences de tactiques
l'essentiel c'est que nous puissions
réaffirmer l'idée d'une coopération
entre les papes plus juste plus solides
plus solidaires tel est le sens
que les députés communistes vont donner
à leur vote je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur Molac pour le groupe
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoires oui merci chers collègues
donc effectivement il y a des gens ici
qui ont une appréciation je dirais
différente par rapport à cette
résolution je note quand même que même
ceux qui voteront contre sont contre
l'accord du Mercosur donc finalement
quelque part notre assemblée est quand
même uneanime et alors je ne suis pas de
ceux qui pensent que tel système ou
telle autre système est forcément bon
forcément mauvais le libre-échange a des
avantages il a des inconvénients mais
bon je dirais à mes camarades que le
socialisme dans un seul pays avait aussi
un certain nombre d'inconvénients donc
le protectionnisme n'est pas forcément
non plus l'alpha et l'oméga de la
protection qu'on peut avoir donc c'est
pour cela que je pense que cette
proposition qui est transpartisane qui a
été élaborée par un certain nombre
d'entre nous et bien tout simplement je
pense qu'il faut la voter effectivement
ça donne à notre gouvernement un cap le
suivra-t-il le suivra t-il pas mais ce
sera notre rôle évidemment de le
contrôler et à un moment donné de lui
dire que nous ne sommes pas d'accord
dans ces cas-là avec ce qu'il fait en
tout cas je note dans cette assemblée et
j'en suis fort satisfait une volonté de
défendre notre agriculture face à des
pratiques qui sont inacceptables et ça
je pense que c'est quand même quelque
chose qui n'était pas forcément sur ses
bancs qui n'était pas forcément unanime
à un moment donné donc on a compris
qu'on ne pouvait pas mettre nos
agriculteurs en concurrence sur des
conditions environnementales et sociales
qui chez nous font que de toute façon
ils sont forcément dans une concurrence
faussée donc nous voterons cette
résolution
et nous espérons évidemment qu'elle sera
tenue à la par le gouvernement à la
suite
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
caroi pour le groupe Renaissance
alors il y a 20 ans l'Union européenne
et les pays du Mercosur initiés de
négociations je serais brève mais c'est
important des négociations bonjour
madame la Présidente pardon et monsieur
le ministre il y a 20 ans l'Union
européenne et les pays du Mercosur
initiés des négociations dans le but de
conclure un accord de libre-échange
européen 40 milliards d'euros de flux
financiers et 780 millions de personnes
concernées si la portée de cet accord
était initialement commerciale de
décennies de négociation complexes l'ont
considérablement transformé nous sommes
loin aujourd'hui de l'accord viande
contre voiture des années 2000 depuis
2019 et de manière inchangée la France
conditionne cet accord au respect de
l'accord de Paris un encadrement de la
déforestation au respect des clauses
miroirs sur les normes sanitaires et
environnementales
si l'élection de Lula l'an dernier
marque un nouveau tournant les
négociations sont toujours en cours la
Commission européenne rencontrera fin
juin les représentants du Mercosur pour
trouver un terrain d'entente sur la
nandendum environnemental transmis en
mars les parties ont indiqué vouloir se
donner les moyens d'atteindre un accord
ambitieux et respectueux de
l'environnement alors qu'est-ce qui est
en jeu aujourd'hui pourquoi sommes-nous
ici la signature du traité UE merco
sourd est un enjeu stratégique pour
l'Europe pour les pays du Mercosur mais
aussi pour la France et pour les
Français c'est un accord qui devrait
nous faciliter l'accès à un immense
marché un marché en pleine croissance
mais aussi en transition écologique dans
ce sens l'accord est une opportunité
pour les entreprises françaises pour
faire valoir leur savoir-faire et se
développer à l'international et cet
accord ne se limite pas à baisser les
droits de douane qui sont d'ailleurs
très élevés il protège nos
investissements à l'étranger il protège
3 37 indications géographiques
européennes comme le jambon de Parme ou
le comté mais ce qui est plus important
à mon sens c'est que cet accord nous
permettra de renforcer les liens avec
l'Amérique latine et c'est un enjeu de
taille parce que pour réduire nos
dépendances à l'égard de la Chine et
atténuer les risques pesant sur les
chaînes d'approvisionnement de matières
premières comme on l'a vu lors de la
guerre en Ukraine c'est un partenariat
stratégique entre des régions qui sont
proches sur le plan des intérêts et des
valeurs l'Union européenne et la mairie
de latine seront mieux placées pour
faire ensemble face au défi du 21e
siècle alors nous devons saisir cette
occasion de renforcer notre partenariat
stratégique avec la mairie de latine
afin d'avancer ensemble pour la défense
d'un système international fondé sur des
règles de droit et qui soit respectueux
de l'environnement car si la France et
l'Amérique latine car si la France est
l'union européenne se détourne de
l'Amérique latine vous savez qui viendra
ce sera la Chine et la Russie elles
seront au rendez-vous et sur et sur
l'environnement parce que vous parlez
d'environnement l'accord de l'Union
européenne et du marque au sûr doit être
un atout qui devrait permettre d'exercer
une influence vertueuse sur la
réglementation mondiale en matière
d'environnement la mairie latine est
vitale pour l'équilibre écologique de la
planète elle représente 50% de la
biodiversité
14% des denrées alimentaires et
constitue une véritable centrale
d'énergie renouvelable il y a quelques
jours à Brasilia j'ai changé avec des
ONG qui sont très actives dans le
domaine de la défense de l'environnement
et vous serez peut-être surpris mais
elles étaient très favorables à ce qu'on
continue à mettre la pression à travers
cet accord pour signer un texte
ambitieux et contraignant sur le volet
environnemental nous nous détournons pas
des régions qui aujourd'hui sont
largement déréguées
alors quelle est ma position personnelle
ma position c'est qu'il ne faut pas vous
y tromper se trouver des prétextes
s'opposer par principe et voter cette
PPR c'est faire le jeu du
protectionnisme et du repli sur soi
depuis 2019 la France maintient et a
réaffirmé à de nombreuses occasions sa
position exigeante et sans équivoque sur
le plan environnemental quel est donc
l'intérêt de signer cette PPR pour dire
ce que la France dit déjà n'en voyons
pas un signal négatif à nos partenaires
d'Amérique latine dans le contexte
actuel après des décennies de
négociation sinueuse les conditions sont
enfin réunies pour nous permettre de
conclure un bon accord la corde merco
sur peut-être il doit être un instrument
efficace pour faire respecter l'accord
de Paris sur le climat
un accord équilibré et permettant de
garantir la diffusion et l'application
de normes environnementale exigeante
par-delà nos frontières parce que nos
frontières toutes celles ça ne sert à
rien alors l'accord merco sur eux ce
n'est pas une fin en soi c'est un chemin
commun pour créer un cadre
institutionnel nécessaire pour favoriser
la coopération entre l'Union européenne
et l'Amérique latine merci dans le
respect de la Merci
je vous remercie je vous rappelle à
toute fin du titre il est d'usage saluer
la présidence le gouvernement ainsi que
vos collègues je vous remercie la parole
est à Monsieur deournois s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît la parole ça me fait
deux pour nasses pour le groupe
rassemblement national merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur chers collègue votre choix
sectaire qui a été celui de faire signer
cette proposition de résolution par des
représentants de l'intégralité des
groupes sans le rassemblement national
est un hommage du vice à la vertu cela
fait en effet 50 ans que nous défendons
la souveraineté contre toutes nos
attaques et tous vos mensonges nous
avons été le phare du bon sens dans
l'océan de vos errements mondialistes
qui ont mis à genoux l'économie
française et particulièrement notre
agriculture nous ne pouvons que nous
réjouir que vous rangiez enfin à cette
impérieux et vitale nécessité de la
souveraineté économique et en
l'occurrence alimentaire mais ce n'est
pas nous qu'il faut convaincre de la
catastrophe si ce traité de
libre-échange avec le Mercosur était
signé
ce n'est pas vous mais vous-même les
macronistes qu'il faut qu'il faut
convaincre à commencer par le Président
de la République qui n'est pas contre le
principe de ce traité de libre-échange
par Monsieur Betsch ministre du Commerce
extérieur qui pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière déclaré que le projet
d'accord a été très proche de la
position du gouvernement ce sont si vos
amis de Renoux qui avec le PPE ne se
pose pas à se traiter de libre-échange
au Parlement européen
nous voterons évidemment cette
résolution qui bien que très
insuffisante va cependant dans le bon
sens mais le travail est colossal alors
que vous même n'en êtes qu'à vos
balbutiements de nouveaux convertis à la
souveraineté alors que la balance
commerciale agricole ne cesse se
dégrader ce sont tous les traités de
libre-échange qu'il faut évidemment
remettre en question contre ce dumping
social et environnemental ce sont des
régulations à toutes les frontières
qu'il faut mettre en place y compris
avec les pays européens en engageant
d'urgence une inflexion du Marché Commun
beaucoup de communication ne trompent
personne le doigt sur la couture vous
avez pris le parti d'être les meilleurs
élèves de l'Union européenne au
détriment des intérêts de la France que
les agriculteurs gardent espoir nous
arrivons
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
trouvée pour le groupe la France
insoumise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
présidente ministre collègue
vous venez monsieur le ministre de faire
une autre caricaturele au libre-échange
et en fait nous n'avons aucun doute sur
ce que vous votez d'ailleurs vous l'avez
dit dans la presse hier soir et ça n'est
qu'une question de temps vous finirez
par voter l'accord de libre-échange
entre l'Union européenne et le Mercosur
il serait bien également il serait
bienvenus également monsieur le ministre
d'éviter les caricatures non nous ne
sommes pas contre le commerce
international nous sommes pour un
commerce international régulé comme ce
fut le cas pendant les trentes
glorieuses
qui fasse que ce commerce ne soit pas le
vecteur d'un dumping social
environnemental et sanitaire
j'en arrive à cette résolution
qui partait sur de bonnes intentions que
notre assemblée puisse débattre et se
prononcer sur la corde avec le Mercosur
oui il le faut et d'ailleurs être
républicain n'est-ce pas c'est s'engager
justement fermement à ce que l'Assemblée
nationale puisse voter cet accord or
vous ne l'avez toujours pas fait
mais cette résolution dit aussi
qu'il faut conditionner l'accord avec le
Mercosur au respect de l'accord de Paris
et des normes sanitaires et
environnementales de l'Europe et bien ça
revient pour nous à accepter le principe
d'un accord de libre-échange et pour
nous un accord de libre-échange vertueux
ça n'existe pas
la résolution
oublie au passage un petit détail les
droits de douane je vous rappelle tout
de même que cet accord prévoit des
droits de douane nul pour d'énormes
quantités de viande de volailles et de
bœuf et je peux vous dire que les
éleveurs français ne feront jamais le
poids face à la libre concurrence
brésilienne ou Argentine
respect
des normes sanitaires ou pas
il ne feront jamais le poids face au
feedlocks et à ses élevages de plusieurs
milliers de bêtes nourris au soja et au
maïs OGM
l'agriculture doit être protégée de
toute libéralisation des échanges quelle
que soit les modalités
car un accord de libre-échange vertueuse
ça n'existe pas
et puis je nous souhaite bonne chance
pour vérifier que ces fameuses normes
sanitaires ces fameuses clauses miroirs
ont bien été respectées au Brésil ou en
Argentine bonne chance pour vérifier
qu'à aucun moment une vache n'aura été
traitée dans sa vie par des hormones de
croissance c'est impossible sur le plan
pratique
c'est impossible aussi sur le plan
juridique puisque comme l'a dit ma
collègue pochon et bien dans un accord
de libre-échange il n'y a pas le droit
de discriminer un produit parce que la
méthode de production est différente
vous voyez bien un accord de
libre-échange vertueux ça n'existe pas
vous conditionnez
vous conditionnez par ailleurs la
signature de cet accord au respect de
l'accord de Paris par les pays du
Mercosur ah bon pourquoi ne pas
mentionner les pays européens
la France est-ce qu'elle respecte
l'accord de Paris
mes collègues vers molasse marquez des
républicains et edel-grières de
renaissance viennent de rendre un
rapport édifiant il faudrait doubler le
rythme de réduction de nos émissions
pour tenir nos engagements de l'accord
de Paris
en réalité pas un seul pays européen a
pris des engagements climats qui lui
permettront de tenir cet objectif
voyez-vous
à la France insoumise nous sommes
altermondialistes
et nous pensons que l'accord de
libre-échange avec le Marco source sera
aussi mauvais pour les éleveurs pour les
paysans européens que pour les paysans
des pays du Mercosur et de ça de cela il
n'en est pas question dans la résolution
il n'y a donc aucune surprise chers
collègues à ce que toute la minorité
présidentielle soit heureuse de porter
cette résolution puisque c'est la
position du président Macron depuis
maintenant deux ans rien de neuf sous le
soleil c'est un peu de greenwashing pour
nous faire avaler l'accord et une fine
et nous ne l'acceptons pas
pour toutes ces raisons chers collègues
nous voterons contre cette résolution
comme
le syndicats dans des organisations
paysannes cette résolution dont les
trois exigences à la position de Macron
merci mais pas suffisante
je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur Brun pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
tout d'abord remercier les différents
groupes qui ont permis la rédaction de
cette proposition de résolution trans
partisane largement inspirée il faut le
dire par les positions de la Fédération
Française bovine se donne-nous
réjouissons n'importe pas l'agriculture
et l'alimentation dont nous ne voulons
pas et faisons de cet accord un accord
de juste échange en faisant un préalable
non négociable du respect de nos normes
sanitaires sociales et environnemental
pour prêter pour protéger notre
agriculture et notre alimentation
finalement c'est un peu paysan et
consommateurs même combat et c'est bien
parce que nous sommes contre le Mercosur
que nous voterons cette résolution en
vous rappelant monsieur le ministre la
question de notre collègue Julien dive
rester sans réponse ou en est la
ratification du CETA au Sénat merci je
vous remercie
nous allons maintenant procéder au
scrutin je vais donc mettre au bois la
propre la proposition de résolution je
vous prie de bien vouloir regagner vos
places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 340
exprimé 339 majorité 170 pour 280 contre
58 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
[Applaudissements]